[Music]
Pope Francis has arrived in South Sudan
on the second leg of his Africa trip
these are pictures from the capital of
Juba the pontiff is going to spend three
days promoting peace and Reconciliation
in the world's youngest country which
has been scarred by Civil War and
poverty hours before he arrived at least
20 people were killed in inter-communal
violence according to the information
Minister well Johnny was on said is Alan
Boswell he's Horn of Africa director for
the international crisis group and host
of the podcast the horn Alan good to
have you with us um so there's been a
five-year War over 380 000 dead this is
a crucial time for this visit for South
Sudan
young South Sudan is a country where
it's almost hard to even pick out the
challenges they are so huge um I the
country tops the list of uh most corrupt
countries in the world the conflict has
been absolutely terrible
um and essentially got independence in
2011 fell into a civil war they got out
of this Civil War
um but violence has actually continued
to climb in much of the country
um and now uh the the food uh in the
Hunger situation continues to grow
um the wfp is saying it's actually the
hungriest satsunis have been since
Independence I want to ask you about the
the food situation and the social
situation in a moment but with regard to
this visit I mean back in 2019 the the
pope created a storm around the world
because he kissed the feet of President
salvakia and first vice president Rick
machar as it was then in order to try to
persuade them to put aside their
differences and stop the violence the
fighting still goes on people must be
wondering what else the church can do to
try to bring bring some sort of end to
the fighting yeah and I think I think
this visit I mean it's not just the pope
it's also the the head of the um of the
the Anglican Church um as well as the
moderator of the Presbyterian Church um
and this really comes from a cry from
the churches in South Sudan um who have
you know seen the state of their country
deteriorate so uh so terribly um and
have been pleading with their leaders
this house in these people have been
pleading with their leaders to try to
make things better they have implemented
a peace deal they signed in 2018 at a
very top level they were able to do
power sharing um but they've basically
implemented almost no other parts of the
agreement the leaders and there's a
variety of leaders but they're all
implicated more or less in in a lot of
the violence that takes place in a lot a
lot of the country
um so for sure the the church's visit
um uh the Pope's visit I think it's to
try to encourage the salesman's people
they've obviously been very
long-suffering I think it's to encourage
the uh the churches as well but there's
obviously a tough message I think they
they want to deliver to the to the
leaders as well after this very powerful
kissing of the feet that the that the
pope did which kind of shocked the world
is shocked to the leaders um but then
we've seen you know South Springs have
been very disappointed in the
performance of their leaders since since
that it's difficult to imagine for
somebody who's on the outside of what
would be going on in the rooms and then
the discussions that will be taking
place what the the pope and his
Entourage and those with them uh would
be able to say what kind of pressure
that they're able to bring on the two
leaders well there's there's very little
clear pressure you can bring
um I I think obviously uh the the church
hopes to to somehow appeal to uh to them
from a from a spiritual from a from a
moral level um and also to and encourage
the church I can say South sunnis
um uh the church I think to a degree and
and diplomats are hoping you know
honestly they're hoping for a miracle in
a sense um I think I think that the the
these church leaders including the pope
will be uh pushing for the leaders to
really make their country better
um and and many diplomats hope that
there's a push to tell them if they
haven't you know that maybe it's time
for them to step aside and let others
try the violence is only part of a cycle
in South Sudan as it is in many other
countries uh in that are affected by
situations like this but we were told
you were mentioning earlier the problems
with uh food security there have been I
think for what four years or so of
continual uh floods which have disrupted
the harvests and of course the violence
is not
um helped with that you end up with a
cycle don't you for of continual
problems it must be very difficult to
find a point at which you can break that
cycle effectively in order to move the
country on yeah South Streets have
really struggled I mean it in essence
they you know when they got independence
it was sort of a botched Independence
because they say they fell so quickly
into Civil War um I was I was there when
they you know um when they got
independence in 2011 and
um there was so much hope there was so
much optimism
um they but they had huge challenges
ahead and the sad thing now is that they
are so much further back uh
um in terms of development but also in
terms of their social cohesion ethnic
tensions are extremely high and so even
getting back to where they were in 2011
feels like a really really steep Road
for South sunnis and like you said it's
it's proven especially difficult because
without necessarily the political
leadership many of them want to see it's
difficult to even know how to start to
change and there's a lot of Goodwill I
think and there was from the
International Community but uh but
they're on eight they can't figure out
exactly how to help really interesting
to get your thoughts on this island boss
well thank you very much indeed for
being with us on Al Jazeera thank you